A story that we've been telling Rosette and stories that we've been telling for
3000 years,
it seems to me to have something to offer.
And so when,
when I look at the stories in the Bible,
I do it,
I would say in some sense with a beginner's mind,
it's a mystery.
This book,
how the Hell it was made,
why it was made,
why we preserved it,
how it happened to motivate an entire culture for 2000 years and to transform
the world.
Like what's going on?
How did that happen?
It's by no means obvious.
And one of the things that bothers me about casual critics of religion is that
they don't take the phenomena seriously.
And it's a serious phenomenon.
I mean,
um,
not at least because people have the capacity for religious experience and no
one knows why that is.
And I mean,
you can induce it reliably and all sorts of different ways.
You could do it with brain stimulation.
You can certainly do it with drugs.
There's,
especially the psychedelic variety,
they produce intimations of the divine extraordinarily regularly.
People have been using drugs like that for God only knows how long,
50,000 years,
maybe more than that,
to produce some sort of intimate union with the divine.
It's like we don't understand any of that.
When we discovered the psychedelics and the late sixties it shocked everybody so
badly that they were instantly made illegal and abandoned in terms of research
for like 50 years.
And it's no wonder because who the hell would expected that nobody.